[Music]
at the start of the movie a man talks
about the chaturanga bart people a group
of ferocious warriors whose courage and
valor were admired by people from all
over he further explains that the first
chaturanka bart warriors were formed in
1605 after the thai army suffered mass
elephant casualties during war their
only purpose was to protect the
elephants and take good care of them for
this they developed a brutal form of
martial art called muay thai hearing
this his son khan becomes intrigued and
expresses his desire to become one of
them he then forms an inseparable bond
with a male elephant named poor eye in
the next scene horyi wanders into the
woods with a female elephant this
worries calm as he assumes his friend is
leaving him but his father calms him
down mentioning that poor yai will come
back the movie then cuts to a few years
later where poryai and the female
elephant cup have given birth to a
healthy calf named corn com has also
grown up to become a deadly chaturanga
bart warrior one day as corn is grazing
in the field some poachers suddenly
surround him but before they can take
him away his parents rush to rescue him
as the poachers begin to flee one of
them accidentally fires his gun and it
hits cop unfortunately she passes away
and little corn is left without a mother
calm is devastated by this but he vows
to protect poor eye and corn at any cost
a few weeks later while calm is out with
corn his father approaches them and
mentions the importance of strong
elephants he reveals that the best
elephants in the country are selected
for the royal king for this a very
intense selection process is conducted
and only the mightiest of elephants can
pass in the next scene comms village
starts preparing for an annual festival
named songkran water festival meanwhile
mr suthep a local mp is throwing a huge
party to celebrate him becoming a member
of the new thai government it's rumored
that they are going to check the
elephants for royal status a local lady
encourages com to take his elephants to
participate in the competition com
reluctantly agrees to take part because
he doesn't want to get separated from
his beloved elephant but also knows that
it's the right thing to do he apologizes
to poryai in advance if he's not able to
see his calf corn again on the day of
the festival khan and his father take
poor eye to mr suthep and his son coy
strangely coy tells calm to wait outside
and takes the elephant and comes father
inside the park where they have kept
other elephants meanwhile khan wanders
around the market with the baby elephant
and buys him a bell the man animal duo
then enjoy blind boxing however calm
gets engrossed in the game and the baby
elephant wanders out on his own
following a group of mischievous
children at the park one of suthep's men
makes calm's father sign some papers
that he can't read and then asks him to
go back home sensing that he's being
fooled calm's father protests and
attacks the mp's son however the latter
becomes enraged and shoots the old man
this in turn angers the elephant and he
starts chasing the man and his henchmen
amidst the chaos a group of men kidnap
the baby elephant wandering outside and
take off com eventually locates his
father and before he passes out he tells
calm about poor eye meanwhile the giant
elephant spots the kidnappers and chases
them throughout the city however the
poachers dart the elephant and disappear
with both the animals a few days later
calm's father eventually recovers and
they perform a traditional oracle
ceremony which is done to find lost
souls in the next scene com somehow
learns about koi's whereabouts and raids
his boathouse the poachers attack him
and a long struggle follows calm is
severely outnumbered but he manages to
beat up the bad guys at last coy tries
to shoot him but com effortlessly
confiscates his gun and intimidates him
into revealing that the elephants are in
the hands of johnny a vietnamese
gangster johnny works for the owner of a
thai restaurant named tom yum goong in
sydney australia before calm could leave
mr suthep arrives and sends his goons
after him both via air and water however
calm somehow evades all the guys and
even manages to crash one of the enemy
boats into the chopper let's see bruce
willis do that two weeks pass by and the
news of the transfer of the elephants to
australia spreads throughout the country
inviting protests from animal activists
meanwhile mr witaya samarat owner of the
thai restaurant tom young gets killed it
is believed that the motive of murder
was wataya's involvement with a chinese
mafia gang and many illegal activities
that could lead to business conflict
between them the movie then cuts to
sydney where police officers mark a thai
australian and his partner rick are
being filmed for a documentary mark is
stationed in the asian neighborhood of
sydney where he knows everyone including
the thieves elsewhere a thai student
named pia is seen being threatened by a
bunch of goons it's revealed that pia is
the girlfriend of the late mr wataya and
the goons are forcing her to be a call
girl to pay her lover's debt next a
transgender member of the chinese gang
named madame rose is seen at a meeting
with the gang's leader and her uncle mr
sim it becomes clear that she wants to
become the head of security of the gang
however mr sim feels that she can't
shoulder the responsibility and tells
her to manage the restaurant instead
much to her dismay com eventually
arrives in sydney however when he hails
a cab and asks the driver jimmy to take
him to tom yung goong a couple of police
cars suddenly start chasing jimmy's car
it turns out jimmy is a wanted thief
posing as a taxi driver mark and his
partner rick also join the chase and
eventually corner the thief but he holds
calm at gunpoint however without the
police's assistance com confiscates
jimmy's god and frees himself out of
nowhere a third policeman inspector
vincent shows up and shoots the thief
dead it turns out vincent has been
following calm since he left the airport
after the thief drops dead he tries to
shoot it calm however he misses the shot
and calm runs for his life puzzled by
vincent's actions mark questions him but
he argues that com was not a hostage and
orders mark and rick to catch him the
duo oblige and start chasing calm
eventually they capture him and drive
towards the police station in the car
com tells mark that he is searching for
his relatives without revealing that the
said relatives are actually elephants
mark stops at the tom yum goong
restaurant to meet an acquaintance there
com spots johnny from inside the car and
becomes erratic he urges mark and rick
to arrest johnny but mark argues that he
cannot because com is offering no proof
of a crime left with no choice calm
causes the car to crash and he escapes
he then follows johnny to a bridge where
the latter was set to meet pia com
confronts jonny and demands his
elephants back however johnny brushes
him aside and orders his henchmen to
take care of calm before leaving a
battle ensues and calm easily overpowers
the henchmen prompting them to run away
as calm goes after them pia warns him
that he shouldn't mess with johnny and
his men however he ignores her advice
and goes after one of johnny's henchmen
he coerces him into leading him to
johnny's hideout interrupting a drug
deal outraged johnny summons countless
extreme sports enthusiasts who arrive to
fight calm they outnumber him and
surround him on all sides a long battle
follows but calm once again triumphs he
then tries pursuing johnny but falls
asleep in the alley due to extreme
fatigue fortunately pia who happens to
pass by notices him on the street and
brings him to her apartment meanwhile
mark and rick are taken off the case for
letting calm escape from a police car
instead they are reassigned to help
vincent provide security for the police
commissioner's meeting with mr sim
elsewhere in his sleep com dreams of an
epic battle involving war elephants and
the jataranka bart the elephant
protectors just then pia gets a call
from the goons she owes money and
decides to head out after she leaves com
wakes up from his dream he looks around
pia's apartment and notices her pictures
with johnny meanwhile the local news
starts reporting that com was involved
in a drug deal in sydney and he is
wanted by the police pia hears the news
on the street and proceeds to return
back to her apartment but she stops and
watches from afar when she notices the
cops arriving outside her place com also
notices the police from inside the
apartment and climbs down the walls to
escape in the next scene it's revealed
that pia is one of the dancers at the
police commissioner's meeting with mr
sim while mark and rick provides
security outside the building unaware of
what's going on inside as pia is dancing
the commissioner gets over excited and
is compelled to seek his medicine to
calm his heartbeat when pia goes to
fetch the medicine an armed assailant
appears and shoots everyone dead except
pia upon hearing the gunshots mark and
rick immediately storm in and confront
the man but vincent appears and takes
down the killer before he can reveal
anything suddenly vincent shoots rick
dead and frames mark for the murder he
then orders his men to arrest mark but
mark manages to flee the murder is
caught on the commissioner's camera and
after vincent and his men go after mark
pia grabs the camera and runs away
vincent eventually captures mark by
luring him to an abandoned building
using a woman from his neighborhood
however vincent realizes that his men
failed to take pia out and she has the
commissioner's camera after a bit of
chasing they eventually arrest her but
as they are about to take her to the
police station com comes to her rescue
and saves her from the corrupt police
after being rescued pia tells calm about
the vip area inside the tom yum goong
and soon he reaches the place he fights
his way into the vip area and reaches
the dining hall at the top there com
demands his elephants but he is only met
with the laughter of johnny and his men
who also taunt him with corn's bell when
com looks around he notices bodies of
several exotic animals and realizes that
vincent probably killed the elephants
and served them to his customers this
enrages calm and he attacks vincent and
his men a long battle follows but just
like always com turns out victorious he
then enters the storage area of the
restaurant and comes across various
exotic animals ready to be butchered and
eaten seeing this com loses all hope but
just then he finds mark tied inside a
room as he looks to escort his friend
outside he suddenly comes across his old
friend corn seeing him calm gets
ecstatic and the trio soon leave the
place in a truck just before the police
arrive meanwhile pia watches them leave
from afar but doesn't go after them
elsewhere during the announcement of the
new leader of the chinese gang madam
rose poisons the two other possible
successors making way for her ascent to
the leadership position meanwhile the
news about the restaurant serving meat
of endangered animals spreads like
wildfire and the police are forced to
close the place after being let down by
johnny once again inspector vincent
initiates a search for calm and mark who
are hiding in a buddhist monastery they
eventually decide to leave the monastery
to keep the goons from attacking it
however soon after their departure the
monastery is set on fire by vincent and
his men believing that the temple and
its inhabitants might be in danger mark
and calm decide to turn around and come
back when they arrive com is confronted
by three assassins a fierce capoeirista
a sword-wielding wushu expert and tk a
giant wrestler com somehow defeats the
caparista and the wushu expert but tk
proves too strong for calm as the giant
is about to eliminate calm the police
arrive and mark comes to help him flee
meanwhile pia goes to the police and
shows mark's boss the video proof which
shows that it was vincent and his men
who killed the police commissioner and
the other people the next morning com
heads out with corn while mark is
discovered by several policemen and sent
a deal with inspector vincent soon khan
arrives at a hall where madame rose is
having a press conference just then corn
runs in scaring off the crowd and calm
starts engaging the gangsters elsewhere
mark apprehends vincent and just as he
is about to arrest him johnny arrives
and fatally shoots vincent mark is left
stunned by the incident but johnny
reveals that it was an act of a revenge
for something personal in the next scene
calm finds himself with corn in a huge
room and he has shown the skeleton of
poor yai encrusted with jewels as a gift
to madame rose this devastates calm and
he starts having flashbacks of his time
with the beloved elephant however he
doesn't get much time to grieve as
madame rose's men attack him filled with
vengeance com attacks them more brutally
than previously seen by breaking many of
the men's arms and legs sensing the
danger madame rose summons tk from the
monastery along with three other
fighters although com tries his best to
match the goons he is easily outnumbered
and subdued soon tk throws corn through
a glass wall while calm is knocked into
the elephant ornament causing two leg
bones to fall off calm realizes that the
tendons are the most vulnerable and
important part of an elephant to protect
and with this knowledge he defeats the
four brute wrestlers by using the sharp
ends of the elephant bones to slice
their tendons he also stops madame rose
before she can escape in a helicopter
and they both crash into the room below
fortunately comes fall is cushioned by
pory's tusks back in the lobby mark
meets his boss inspector lamonde and
gets forgiven by him he is then given a
new partner who speaks tai in the last
scene of the movie a narration from mark
is heard with scenes of calm's childhood
shown mark explains that thai people
treat elephants like they are their
brothers and they hate people who hurt
them thais love peace but dislike people
who take liberties the movie ends as
calm finally embraces his best friend
corn subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching